est-ce qu'on nous sommes encore une
grande puissance oui vous avez raison de
vous poser la question mais le problème
n'est pas tant d'être une grande
puissance
le problème est d'être une puissance
utile bon une puissance utile il faut
pas se tromper de cheval si vous passez
votre temps à courir derrière les
américains et à passer par toutes leurs
lubies et sous stratégie par exemple a
désigné les russes comme des adversaires
alors que maintenant enfin même le
président de la république reconnaît que
les rues sont des partenaires vous vous
trompez de cheval parce que l'intérêt
fondamental de la france et de
s'entendre avec les russes alors on me
dit oui mais leur régime ne nous
convient pas ben c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
et pourtant sous le régime soviétique
c'est le général de gaulle qui a fait un
accord avec pareil pour la chine
nous sommes le premier pays à avoir
reconnu la république populaire de chine
le 1er pendant un temps les seuls et
alors donc la france pacte avec des
nations avec des peuples donc il ne faut
pas se tromper de cheval nous n'avons
rien à faire dans derrière la locomotive
américaine qui nous pillent nos
capacités intellectuelles et productive
qui nous mène comme ça à la trique vous
savez le dandé dans des impasses parce
que voyez le l'embargo qui a été mis sur
certains produits russes les seuls à qui
ça profite s et les russes parce qu'ils
ont remplacé les légumes et les fruits
que les européens notamment les français
produisent et s'était même qui les
produisent mais ça n'a jamais empêché un
seul jour les compagnies
nord-américaines de continuer à exporter
chez les russes qui rigole parce qu'ils
savent très bien que y'a pas station
spatiale internationale sans leurs
fusées pour y amener du monde parce
qu'ils savent très bien que tout ça n'a
aucun sens
cette agressivité qui est développée
contrôlant maintenant ça s'est calmé
alors on est en train de s'en prendre
aux chinois ce qui est sans issue de
même la france doit pas se tromper
elle doit coopérer de manière non
alignés et je suis le porte parole si
j'ose dire de cet indépendantiste
français de ce non alignement
ça veut dire contre la politique de
personnes c'est encore possible alors
même que vous le disiez militairement
on a besoin des américains pour
quasiment tous pour quoi faire
je sais pas fournir aux russes et aux
chinois mais pour louis mais c'est à ça
que ça se résume la puissance
nord-américaine coopèrent et veut qu'au
concours pair avec elle pour mener ces
guerres invraisemblable mené d'ailleurs
en dépit du bon sens parce que qu'on
m'explique ce qu'on a fait pendant
presque
maintenant je sais pas combien d'années
depuis 2001 que nous y sommes donc ça va
faire bientôt vingt ans c'est quoi le
résultat en afghanistan c'est quel était
le but d'ailleurs les gens se rappelle
même plus un on nous avait dit rien là
pour libérer les femmes vont très bien
mais on a confié la constitution à une
assemblée traditionnelle
on y ajouter vous le savez peut-être la
plus grosse bombe de l'histoire humaine
a été jeté sur l'afghanistan par les
nord américains si une banque
conventionnelle mais la plus grosse qui
ait jamais été fabriquée de l'histoire
c'est une puissance de feu équivalente à
celle d'hiroshima
personne ne sais ni pourquoi on a jeté
cette bombe ni quel résultat on en
attendait nickel résultat ça a donné
donc tout ça c'est l' empire fait la
guerre comme une espèce de deux
mécanismes économiques intérieurs
[Musique]